pour décrypter ce qui est en train de se
jouer et sur le terrain et entre les
différentes chancelleries notre invité
je me tourne vers notre invité du jour
jean vincent brisset et bonjour
chercheur associé à l'iris général de
brigade aérienne auteur par ailleurs de
manuels de l'outil militaire comprendre
le fonctionnement des armes est certain
c'est ces dernières heures
ont eu tendance à estimer que vladimir
poutine et son armée était en grande
difficulté d'où ces rumeurs on en
reparle dans quelques instants de
demande à l'aide formulées à la chine
démenti et par les russes et par les
chinois mais j'aimerais d'abord
recueillir votre votre sentiment à vous
en ce début d'après midi le kremlin
vient tout juste de réagir de faire
savoir que son armée n'excluait pas de
prendre le contrôle total des grandes
villes ukrainiennes le kremlin qui
réitère et qui affirme que tout se passe
comme prévu et que cette guerre ira
jusqu'à jusqu'à son terme dans les temps
impartis
alors effectivement à l'heure actuelle
les informations dont on peut disposer d
informations ouvert présente on peut
disposer font état d'un côté de dans la
plupart des médias occidentaux d'une
démoralisation de l'armée russe de
difficultés de problèmes de soldats qui
désertent de problèmes de carburant et
autres et c'est toutes ces informations
ressemblent en même quelquefois plus
fort à ce qui est dans les communiqués
quotidiens que je reçois régulièrement
du ministre de la défense ukrainien
de l'autre côté quant au regard de ce
qui se passe sur le terrain il semble
que petit à petit sans sens à grandes
avancées et sans grand combat les armées
russes avancent doucement et forme par
le nord par le sud et par l'est forment
une espèce de tenaille à l'intérieur de
laquelle la moitié de l'armée
ukrainienne risque d'être coincé et puis
ensuite il ya des points particuliers
comme mario paul par exemple donc si je
vous suis bien finalement aujourd'hui ça
prendra le temps que ça prendra mais au
final les russes atteindront
probablement leur leurs objectifs est-ce
qu'elle allait les moyens de cette
guerre là russe est ce qu elle a aussi
les moyens que ce conflit s'éternise
alors ça c'est dit c'est difficile à
dire le l'armée russe elle a eu enfin le
problème de départ c'est que l'armée
russe les dirigeants russe et là aussi
on parle beaucoup de poutine à mon avis
le problème et plus largement dans
l'entourage immédiat de poutine qui l'a
sans doute pas informés de ce qui se
passait réellement et des possibilités
réelles mais l'armée russe espérée dans
les deux trois premiers jours faire un
tel coup de poing une telle un tel choc
que le régime de kiev actuelle
s'effondre et qu'ils puissent être
remplacés ou une négociation puisse
avoir lieu pour obtenir un petit peu les
buts de guerre actuelle de poutine ça
l'a pas lieu il y à une réorganisation
est ce que cette réorganisation
est quelque chose qui était planifié
j'en ai pas l'impression
et est-ce que poutine ne découvre pas
que ses généraux ses conseillers là
aussi très difficile de savoir à quel
niveau ça se passe l'ont trompé et je
dois affirmer que les possibilités
étaient ouvertes alors qu'elle n'était
pas vraiment le new york times journal
américain a estimé un ces dernières
heures que les russes avaient
réclamé
de l'aide à pékin que la russie s'était
tourné vers versons son principal allié
aujourd'hui lui réclamant une aide
militaire déjà dans un premier temps
doux mais question est ce que l'armée
russe étant est en bon état aujourd'hui
une aide économique pour contourner a
notamment les sanctions internationales
son show financière qui était un fichier
réaction depuis du kremlin qui a
évidemment démenti réaction aussi ce
matin de la chine très en colère on va
on va écouter le ministre chinois des
affaires étrangères à ce propos on vient
juste après
les états unis ont récemment diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes la position
de la chine sur la question de l'ukraine
a été claire et cohérente on m'a dit
djilla nous avons toujours joué un rôle
constructif en appelant à la paix et aux
négociations la question la plus urgente
à l'heure actuelle est que toutes les
parties fassent preuve de retenue
refroidissant la situation tendue au
lieu de jeter de l'huile sur le feu et
favorise une résolution diplomatique au
lieu d'aggraver la situation ce juge tié
bi
chinois est ce que ça vous paraît
plausible cette information américaine
envers ma thèse sur le contexte avait
des rencontres entre américains et
chinois ce matin donc juste après ces
déclarations est ce que ça vous paraît
plausible que les russes se tourner vers
l'allié chinois pour lui demander une
aide aujourd'hui quelles qu'elles soient
côté je me souviens de ce qui s'est
passé à voir le 24 février et jusqu'au
25 ou 26 février où les un certain
nombre de commentateurs ont dit que en
jetait la russie dans les bras de la
chine est effectivement la russie a un
oeil vers la chine depuis toujours même
si les relations
peuvent être difficiles et même s'il n'y
a jamais eu une relation sur le long
terme entre la russie et la chine mais à
l'heure actuelle la chine pourrait
constituer à déboucher et d'un autre
côté pour le chinois
réussir à former un bloc avec la russie
sachant que les chinois envisagerait à
ce moment là d'être les leaders de ce
bloc peut être une option intéressante
donc on est dans quelque chose de
compliqué il ya aussi quelque chose on a
très peu parlé ce sont les liens qui
lient les bureaux d'études ukrainiens et
les marchands de canons ukrainien avec
la chine qui se sont vus chrétiens qui
ont été très largement
coopérant pour permettre la montée en
puissance de l'armée chinoise
donc on est dans quelque chose que sont
très délicates pour la chine aujourd'hui
on l'a senti dès le départ et ça ça ne
fait que se confirmer un finalement tout
à fait et la chine aimerait bien se
retrouver lié avec la russie dans un
bloc à peu occident anti occidental ne
serait ce que parce que la russie qui
est à l'heure actuelle encore assez
réticente pour fournir des technologies
qu'elle possède à la chine pourraient
être amenés à le faire en échange d'un
soutien économique dont la russie aura
bien besoin dans les années qui viennent
on dit que la chine qui affirme une
neutralité pro-russe a pour plan
d'acheter bien plus tard la russie après
discount ça vous inspire ça comme jean
de cette gens de vue
ça m'inspire pas mal parce que on parle
beaucoup de taïwan mais dans les
revendications chinoises depuis
l'arrivée de mao au pouvoir surtout au
début des années 50 il ya les
territoires qui ont été volés entre
guillemets à la chine par la russie les
par les traités de pékin elle traitait
des gones c'est un million de kilomètres
carrés dans l'extrême orient soviétique
merci beaucoup jean vincent brisset vous
étiez notre invité du jour